aurélien pradié députés les républicains
et sébastien jumel du parti communiste
français
pourtant ils s'engagent ensemble sur la
question du handicap
la visite de l'ime du breuil a été
suivie d'une discussion avec des parents
d'enfants porteurs d'un handicap les des
responsables d'associations
le but de cette visite était de se
confronter à la réalité du terrain
force est de constater que des progrès
ont été enregistrés mais qui reste du
pain sur la planche pour que le parcours
du combattant des familles quoi terminer
et que le droit à la scolarisation des
enfants on établissements ou au milieu
ordinaire ne soit pas un droit formel
maladroit réel durant cette visite c'est
la question de la scolarisation des
enfants porteurs d'un handicap qui a été
largement abordée pour les parents
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable parcours
du combattant
les enfants sont scolarisés on a entendu
tout à l'heure cette maman qui disait
que sa fille a été scolarisée à une
époque une demi heure par jour
que voulez-vous faire comme
scolarisation intelligente avec une demi
heure par jour
donc nous ce qu'on préconise au niveau 2
de nos associations et du réseau une api
au niveau national c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas de saupoudrage qui consiste à donner
quelques petites miettes et à dire comme
ça les enfants une solution non on est à
très très attentif au fait qu'il faut
que ce soit aussi de qualité et non pas
seulement de quantité une meilleure
collaboration entre les différents
services de l'état est préconisée par
les associations pour un meilleur
fonctionnement
je pense qu'il va falloir que ce qu'ils
se soient travailler c'est une
collaboration entre le médico social et
l'éducation nationale l'éducation
nationale à ses compétences nous avons
nos compétences et si on les croise en
arrivera des choses très positives
au total le département des yvelines
compte 24 instituts médico éducatifs